I was I was saying as we started that
it's every actor in Hollywood and dune
but you I know well I think it's Oscar
saying I could play one of the big worms
maybe I want to start by saying how much
I enjoyed this movie it is a great film
congratulations I'm out I actually
wanted to bring up something actually a
little more serious
I there's been a lot of talk in the last
few days about Netflix movies and Oscars
and a lot of people are debating it I'm
of the opinion that a Netflix movie
absolutely should be eligible for an
Oscar if it plays for a week in a
theater have you heard about this
controversy do you have any a lot of
people different opinions I mean there's
there's people who feel like four week
window is you know there's a movement
within some people to Kadim you say
should be four weeks in France you can't
get a theatrical release I think until
you have a 39 month window so there's a
whole spectrum of people and you know
obviously Netflix has to figure out the
relationship with can because they don't
want you know can't again the French
have been very proprietary about showing
films that are gonna be on streaming
services and preserving what they feel
is the integrity of the cinema writ
large I think it's one of these things
that's a question that's just ongoing
and hasn't been resolved yet technology
is changing movies are changing that we
who watch movies changing and I think
it'll shake out and then it'll change
again you know the movie business has
evolved through you know silent movies
talkies color you know people thought
television we're gonna destroy movies
you know and that movies ministry radio
it ultimately I feel like great stories
by great storytellers like Alfonso
Cuaron among others who working for
Netflix on you know are what people want
to see you know I think probably more
important than the platform that is the
best answer
I appreciate thanks I figure you've been
answered asked a lot of the same
questions today I'm going to try to
throw something you have not been asked
which is getting to work with guy norris
he is a tremendous second unit director
and i love that he's always about doing
it practically without cg
I can you talk a little bit about
collaborating with him and the
experience of making this film I think
particularly the vehicle work we got to
do towards the end of the film they came
up with this whole rig that was like
this like little go-cart track around
the truck that we were in and the camera
would just spin around that thing I
think it was done with magnets and looks
like this kind like the old old racing
cars with the electric yeah it was
incredible and so he would actually be
in the car
Pedro was driving the truck Charlie was
right next to him I'm in the back we're
shooting these you know full loaded
blanks and this cameras just spinning
around us then they and then guy had his
these amazing drivers just like flying
off these dunes
it was amazing to be a part of that to
see the way that he would work and watch
it on the screen he's incredible fuels I
mean he's definitely as you said if if
stuff feels in camera it's gonna I think
feel more urgent or in me even and you
can do a ton of effects like a first man
which I think won the Oscar for FX you
know they made it all feel very felt
like it wasn't plastic it wasn't just a
bunch of CG it was very immediate and
urgent and real and that seemed to be
guys philosophy and III to my personal
taste I already got to go
congratulations on the movie
you